there are still thousands of frightened
families trying to get out of
afghanistan
and the taliban doesn't want you to see
this
this is not the image they want right
now
our paper permissions issued by the
taliban themselves are suddenly
worthless
they want to control what the media
covers and importantly who leaves the
country and stop this mass exodus
only a handful of airlifts have been
allowed since the taliban took charge of
the airport many of them like this one
organized by the state of qatar but now
even they are struggling under the
pressure explain who you're taking and
who you're not taking
it's very simple
how day before how day before coming
here by passport
who had valid passport not expire who
had visa
that said he can live he can live
with
everyone
every british people is here yeah we do
have british cities
but the numbers wanting to leave far
outstrip the flights the uk government
insists it's going as fast as it can but
on the ground there's a lot of criticism
for leaving people stranded here we have
an army to take us out of here not we
have the army we paid at the taxpayer
to occupy other countries instead of
that they did like this
supposed to help us
this video taken a few years ago shows
taliban fighters beating an afghan
journalist and the beating isn't enough
with his hands tied he's dragged along
by motorbike and he then spent two days
being tortured by the taliban for his
reporting
he's now trying to flee the country
scared for his life
i think if they arrest me again and
on the time i was a journalist
and this time they will kill me
some of his family are uk citizens
butchers from essex now they all feel
targets
there's no response for anybody we email
and there's nobody
in this country to someone
help us
others fled the taliban to the uk when
children and only returned to save their
families but are now trapped and facing
the danger all over again
how can i look after my family how can i
how can i look after myself
why uh quite
scary
for me the situation of taliban
that when i was seeing the taliban
quite scary for me
the flightless are agreed with the
foreign governments including the
british but qatari officials then have
to navigate the taliban
we were told along with hundreds of
others who were on the flight list that
the taliban had struck us off
we joined the convoy to the airport
anyway but there were no women to carry
out the female body searchers and no
immigration officials
filming discreetly because of taliban
disapproval we saw all the passengers
forced to leave the airport for another
night of waiting and the plane left
kabul without anyone on board
the next day the families go through the
whole process all over again with many
of them telling us they've waited a
month to get to this stage fearful right
up to the last moment they'll be turned
back
our foreign office
they called me twice
in almost a month
did you think you were gonna end up
being trapped here yeah
i feel abandoned and hopeless at least
i'm going home now
they leave not knowing if they'll ever
be back in afghanistan and knowing
thousands remain left behind
alex crawford sky news kabul